The last practice I want to mention is on-site customer, and what
that means is that literally the customer is an actual member of
the team. So the customer will sit with the team and will
bring requirements to the team and discuss the requirements with them. So
the typical objection to this practice is the fact that it's just
impossible in the real world. There is no way that the customer
can have one person staying with the team all the time, and
the answer to that objection is that if the system is not
worth the time of one customer then maybe the system is not worth building. In
other words, if you're investing tons of
dollars, tons of money in building a system,
you might just as well invest a little more and have one of the people
in the customer's organization stay with the
team and be involved in the whole process.